más de dos días después del terremoto
que sacudió el lunes por la madrugada el
sur de Turquía del Norte sería las
tareas de rescate continúan en muchos
sitios como este en osman y una de las
localidades más afectadas no es la que
más pero es una de las más afectadas y
aquí hay cientos de muertos
en la zona ocurrió un terremoto terrible
a las 4:20 de la madrugada todo se
escapábamos al exterior y en la ciudad
180 edificios han quedado destruidos
en nuestro edificio no quedó nada las
casas de muchos amigos Están destruidas
conocía mucha gente que murió
todos los aquí presentes están muy
atentos a lo que ocurre en mis espaldas
en una de las tareas de rescate donde
supuestamente según cuentan estos
vecinos ahí entre 30 y 50 personas
atrapadas hasta aquí son esperando que
sus seres queridos hermanos familiares e
incluso amigos puedan seguir con vida
sin embargo explican todos ellos que las
probabilidades a esta hora son muy muy
bajas
llevamos más de dos días delante de este
edificio esperando cuando llegamos al
principio escuchamos que había gritos
desde el interior en esos momentos el
equipo de rescate era pequeño porque
estaba ocurriendo en todos lados estamos
esperando a jalaba a burak de 20 años la
joven miseria y rezamos
todos los que nos hemos quedado sin casa
hemos venido aquí porque aquí es donde
llega la ayuda y es más seguro ahora
mismo pero dentro de este edificio tengo
a mi hermana y a mi sobrino estamos
esperando a las 80 personas que hay
dentro de ese edificio 16 departamentos
si en cada uno había cuatro personas
serían unas 100 se sacaron unas 20
quedan 80 dentro el primer día no llegó
ayuda por culpa del colapso y del mal
tiempo nuestras vidas han quedado en
manos de Dios Así que esperamos en el
primer día escuchábamos gritos desde
adentro ahora ya no
en todo el sur de Turquía y también el
norte de Siria hay miles de edificios
como estos ahora llenos de personal de
rescate que luchan contrarreloj para
intentar salvar a las personas que
puedan quedar con vida cada día y cada
minuto que pasa según nos dicen los
vecinos hay menos posibilidades muchos
Incluso se resignan ya de que sus seres
queridos van a aparecer por culpa del
terremoto del lunes por la madrugada en
los muertos suman ya más de 10.000
personas y esa cifra en los próximos
días no hará más que aumentar